in the wake of news report suggesting
that the Clinton Foundation may be
targeted for indictment by an FBI
investigation and the private email
server was indeed hacked no less than
five times but foreign intelligence
agencies the 2016 Democratic nominee was
asked whether she would fire the current
FBI director James Comey
if she would be elected president here
was her answer yesterday quote I'm not
going to get ahead of myself by assuming
I'll be fortunate enough to be elected
that's up to you and your listeners
people have to turn out or nothing I'm
going to be proposing will come into
reality but I would also never comment
on any kind of personnel issue reports
but attorney general Loretta Lynch's
Justice Department has put severe
pressure on the FBI to drop the Clinton
Foundation investigation according to
The Wall Street Journal this is a direct
quote
officials at Justice Department
headquarters sends a message to all the
offices involved to stand down a person
familiar with the matter said a senior
Justice Department official called the
FBI deputy director mr. McCabe on August
12th to say agents in New York seemed to
be disregarding or disobeying their
instructions the conversation was a
tense one they said at one point mr.
McCabe asked quote are you telling me I
need to shut down a validly predicated
investigation the senior Justice
Department official replied of course
not
yeah right all of which means that the
American people are now forced into the
position of using this election as a
law-enforcement tool we are supposed to
be the judge and the jury and the
political executioner's that's because
we don't trust the FBI anymore to be
impartial and we definitely don't trust
the DOJ to enforce the law and partially
not after Eric Holder and Loretta Lynch
if we did trust those institutions
Hillary wouldn't have any problems she
could simply say look look I'm guilty
then I'll be prosecuted you elected me
and then DOJ and have founded their job
and the law will just work how it's
supposed to but that doesn't have any
credibility in a world where the FBI
director refused to recommend the
indictment for a clear and obvious crime
and then announced a reopened
investigation based on unclear factors
none of that has any credibility when
the DOJ has become the legal arm of the
President of the United States so we the
people have to decide should Hillary be
allowed to run the very agencies of
government tasked with enforcing law
against her should trump be elected
simply to allow the gears of law
enforcement
turn properly in this light you know
crowds chanting lock her up it starts to
look a lot more reasonable since the
opposite is crowds chanting elect
Hillary so she can take over the FBI
ngoj and stop from own imprisonment
corruption in our government forces us
to be the law-enforcement body of last
resort that is tragic but unfortunately
that's the way it is I'm Ben Shapiro
this is the Ben Shapiro show
so tons to get to today and I'm sorry
but you know podcast yesterday I was on
the road yesterday at speaking at TCU or
we had 500 students full house 150
people out in the lobby wonderful event
I'm headed to University of Texas at
Austin today which should be another
party and and then we're gonna head back
home but I went to an ignite we're gonna
do the mailbag a little bit later so
stick around for that lots going on
today first we have to say hello to our
friends over at Birch gold so Birch gold
is the place where you want to go if
you're interested in buying precious
metals they have a free kit that they'll
give you a 16-page kit that tells you
all about investing in precious metals
if you go to birchgold.com slash Ben
they'll teach you how to take a 401k or
your out of your IRA and move it into a
move it into gold move it into precious
metals which may be something that's
worthwhile considering how much
uncertainty we're about to experience in
the economy no matter who's elected
there's tremendous amounts of
uncertainty in this entire election and
so if you're looking to at least take
some of your money and put it in
precious metals as a hedge against
inflation and uncertainty birchgold.com
/ Ben is the way to do it again
birchgold.com / Ben
okay so tell us to get to here I want to
start with the latest in electoral news
so do we have this this map when you
post that map okay so this is what the
electoral map believe it or not could
look like this is worst case scenario
what the electoral map could look like
on Tuesday worst case scenario a to 69
to 69 tie and no this is actually not
out of the realm of possibility this map
is actually the map that you get if
Hillary wins all of Maine if Trump
doesn't win any Maine votes but Trump
wins New Hampshire and he went into
Arizona and Georgia and Florida and Ohio
and Iowa and North Carolina if he wins
all of those states anyone's New
Hampshire this will be he will have 269
electoral votes Hillary Clinton will
also have 269 electoral votes that is
not remotely outside the realm of
possibility if there is a tie then this
goes to the House of Representatives
which decides but you assume these are
gonna be a lot of closed States which
means you're gonna get four or five
recounts instead so if you like 2000
worst-case scenario this could be two
thousand times a thousand it could be
just awful all the way through if this
ends up as a tie but all the
in trump's corner right now there are
two new polls out of New Hampshire that
show Trump up which is really amazing he
was down double digits and most of the
polls just two weeks ago there's a poll
yesterday that shows him up in Virginia
that's one poll among many there's polls
that show him down in Florida there's
polls that show him up in Florida all
the polls basically have him up you know
high up all the polls basically have him
up in Iowa run clear what's going on in
Nevada there's some polls where he's up
some polls where he's down unclear where
it is in North Carolina a lot of
uncertainty in this race you know my own
take on the race is this it feels a lot
a lot like 2012 where Romney made a big
surge at the end and Republicans
including me thought Romney was going to
win and then his turnout game just
wasn't Obama's turnout game and Obama
ended up eliminating winning on the
basis of turnout we have no idea what
the turnout is gonna be like this year
because Trump has built no ground game
Hillary does have a ground game
so just realistically speaking Trump's
gonna have to have a lot of very
enthusiastic people and Hillary is gonna
have to have a lot of very
unenthusiastic people which could happen
which is why I'm not ruling out the
possibility of a trump win if I had put
money on it right now I think the
betting markets are basically correct I
think that essentially this is about a
6535 chance that Hillary is that is the
President of the United States come next
in coming next next Wednesday morning
but this is way too close to call for
Hillary Clinton and you can tell by the
way that she's losing her mind and she
should be losing her mind because every
day there is new news that is breaking
it's amazing every day there's more news
breaking about how corrupt Hillary is
and how deep this FBI investigation goes
so last night breath there was on Fox
News and he announced a bunch of details
about this this FBI investigation into
Hillary Clinton including the fact that
she was lying basically when she said
that her server had never been hacked
apparently her private server was hacked
no less than five times by five
different foreign intelligence agencies
according to Brett the air here was
there last night two separate sources
with intimate knowledge of the FBI
investigations into the Clinton emails
and the Clinton Foundation tell Fox the
following the investigation into the
Clinton Foundation looking into possible
pay-for-play interaction between
Secretary of State Hillary Clinton and
the foundation has been going on for
more than a year led by the White
crime division public corruption branch
of the Criminal Investigative Division
of the FBI the Clinton Foundation
investigation is a quote very high
priority agents have interviewed and re
interviewed multiple people about the
foundation case and even before the
WikiLeaks dumps these sources said
agents had collected a great deal of
evidence pressed on that one source said
quote a lot of it and there is an
avalanche of new information coming in
every day some of it from WikiLeaks
some from new emails the agents are
actively and aggressively pursuing this
case and they will be going back and
interviewing the same people again some
for the third time as a result of the
limited immunity deals to a number of
top aides including Cheryl Mills and
Heather Samuelson the Justice Department
had tentatively agreed that the FBI
would destroy those laptops after a
narrow review we are told definitively
that has not happened and those devices
are currently in the FBI field office
here in Washington DC and are being
exploited it's an amazing amazing story
I mean he's he's exposing all of these
details and none of them are good for
Hillary Clinton these are all a disaster
for Hillary Clinton the chairman of the
House Homeland Security Committee Mike
McCaul from Texas he says that Hillary
Clinton could face impeachment over this
stuff even if she's elected this
investigation will continue whether she
wins or not but assuming she wins and
the investigation goes forward and it
looks like an indictment is pending at
that point time under the Constitution
the House of Representatives would
engage in an impeachment trial they
would go to the Senate and impeachment
proceedings and removal would take place
remember this the last time I can recall
when this happened was Richard Nixon he
was impeached and resigned before he
would have been voted to remove office
and then a member of Gerald Ford
pardoned him from any criminal
wrongdoing I would hate to see this
country being thrown into a
constitutional crisis because of Hillary
Clinton's behavior and that's what we're
facing McCall is right I mean we are
facing the prospect of Hillary Clinton
being alive
facing impeachment although the chances
of her actually being impeached tried
and convicted in the Senate are
extraordinarily low but that doesn't
mean that she won't be hampered for her
entire presidency which may be the only
good news if Hillary Clinton were to be
elected as that she would be a weak
president no one would take her
seriously the Congress would buck her
routinely because after all she's so
corrupt they don't have to pay any
attention to her but it is amazing so
the American people are being asked now
as I said before to be law enforcement
it's our job now to be law enforcement
because Hillary could come in she could
wipe out the FBI she could put her own
people in a DOJ they already are she
could put more of her own people in a
DOJ prevent any investigation from going
forward basically be Nixon right Nixon's
are in Watergate there was a special
prosecutor and he basically had him
fired in what was called the Saturday
night massacre Hillary could do the same
thing using the DOJ and she could fire a
bunch of people at the FBI to protect
herself which would necessitate
impeachment from Congress it could be a
full-scale disaster wouldn't be
surprised that too Hillary Clinton is
now that's only if Hillary wins so right
now because of all of this a lot of
Americans are looking at Hillary and
going we're not sure about this this
does not look so good like we're not
enamored of Trump but as long as Trump
shuts his mouth and stays out of the way
and we have to look Hillary Clinton as
president directly in the face that is
an ugly ugly idea I mean not because of
her face per se but because this is just
the idea of Hillary Clinton its
president is just horrendous it's too
corrupt to to contemplate Democrats are
freaking out about this Barack Obama in
particular is losing his mind over this
Obama is is largely responsible for
Hillary Clinton being in the predicament
she's in under Barack Obama the
Democrats have lost at the state level
well over 900 seats in various state
legislatures they lost 12 governorships
they've lost 13 Senate seats they've
lost an enormous number of house seats
they've done that because Barack Obama's
coalition is not the traditional
Democratic coalition the traditional
democratic voting coalition is largely
dependent on working-class white voters
Obama wiped that off the map for
Democrats in 2012 the working-class
white vote went from Mitt Romney instead
Obama won on the basis of very very
strong minority turnout the prowl
and I've been saying this for a couple
of years it's not replicable just
because Obama was able to get lots of
black people to vote doesn't mean
Hillary would be able to get a lot of
black people to vote and that's what's
happening right now a lot of the
constituencies that Obama alienated are
moving over to Trump now the sad thing
is that if Republicans had runs someone
who wasn't such a crap show like Trump
and they kept Romney's constituencies
and added the ones that that Obama has
alienated this would've been a wipeout I
mean this one I'm gonna wipe out for
Republicans imagine if Republicans had
gotten that white working-class vote
with some other candidate and not
alienated the college-educated female
vote which is now going for Hillary
Clinton that went for Romney last time
if it were a narrow gap Trump would be
up by five in the polls right now he's
not because who he is but Obama is
looking around he's going all of this
was about me and I'm not gonna have
anybody to pick up the pieces after I'm
gone
and Obama is I mean he is granted the
most narcissistic man in America and
that includes Donald Trump I mean Obama
is a true narcissist because Trump
thinks he is all of these wonderful
things and he isn't Obama also thinks
that but he's smart enough to know about
her and and he still has no humility
about who he is it's truly amazing this
is a guy who after the Cubs won last
night he actually came forward and asked
the comes to visit the White House well
he's still president she's gonna steal
that honor from the next president of
the United States because he has to be a
part of it typical Obama I thought it
was a White Sox fan by the way she
shouldn't be quite so eager to have it
comes to the White House but there we
are Obama is out there on the campaign
trail and he is freaking out and you can
tell that this race is a lot closer than
Democrats want it to be by the attitude
that they're using here's Obama freaking
out about the possibility of a Donald
Trump presidency
I've got Republican friends who don't
think or act the way Donald Trump does
this is somebody who is uniquely
unqualified I ran against John McCain I
ran against Mitt Romney I thought I'd be
a better president but I never followed
that the Republic was at risk if they
were elected
and guess what North Carolina the good
news is all of you are uniquely
qualified to make sure hey whose
uniquely unqualified does not become
president you just got a vote okay and
so he said I hate this sort of hypocrisy
from Barack Obama so I think that Trump
is an outlier meaning I don't think he's
in the same line of Republicans as
McCain and Romney I don't think he's a
good man I don't think that he's a
conservative but Democrats don't get to
play this game where I've never said
I've never believed that Republicans
were unqualified for office before that
they couldn't be that the country be
ruined I'm old enough to remember when
Joe Biden your vice president was saying
in the in the run-up to the 2012
election that if Mitt Romney were
elected president of the United States
black people would be put back into
chains that would be a pretty big threat
to the Republic wouldn't it his entire
campaign slogan back in 2012 Obama's was
that Mitt Romney wants to send you back
to the 1950s presumably when women were
in the kitchen and black people were
still under the thumb of Jim Crow okay
so the idea that Obama's gonna stand
there and now he's gonna say yeah I've
always been cordial the Republicans but
not from from was different it just
doesn't it doesn't fly you cried wolf
enough times when the actual wolf shows
up at the door nobody believes you well
I was also panicking because he thought
he could just tell black people to vote
for Hillary and they'd show up and vote
for Hillary it turns out that black
people are not just pawns of Barack
Obama and a lot of them are not enamored
of Hillary and they just don't care that
much so Obama is trying to is trying to
lecture black people about how they need
to they need to vote more and and I'm
gonna be honest with you right now
because we track we've got early voting
we've got all kinds of metrics to see
what's going on and right now the Latino
vote is up overall vote is up but they
ask an American vote right now there's
not as solid as it needs to be and I
know that there are a lot of people and
barbershops and the beauty salons you
know in the neighborhoods who are saying
to themselves well you know we love
black we love that we especially love
Michelle and so you know it was exciting
and and now we're not excited as much
and you know
I need everybody to understand that
everything we've done is dependent on me
being able to pass the baton to somebody
who believes in the same things I
believer I mean this is really perverse
language it's it's it's the language of
dictatorship right he's dictating to the
black community and the barbershops I
mean if a white person said this think
he'll race to start soon yeah I know
there are a lot of black people and
they're in the barbershops and the hair
salons it's like really black people
aren't anywhere except for barbershops
but here's Barack Obama telling black
people listen I'm telling you you need
to vote for my successor because I'm
handing off the baton go out there
because I'm black and you're black you
listen to me it really is disgusting
stuff we have take a quick break say
hello to our friends at D s TLD if you
it's just still but it's D s TLD calm
slash been and this is where you go if
you want a great pair of jeans so D s
TLD that they're jeans instead of
costing a couple of hundred dollars
which you can pay for for a nice pair of
jeans and they start at 65 bucks they
cut out the retail middlemen it's direct
to you and they are they're very
efficient and how they and how they
build their their clothes and how they
and how they create the clothes and the
kind of materials that they use but
these are legitimate jeans that are
great I have a pair of them they're one
of my favorite pairs of jeans they fit
terrific they're really really
comfortable and they are really cheap in
fact I went back and I bought a second
pair of jeans because I thought that it
was such a deal
it's a DST LD calm slash Ben you get ten
bucks off your first pair so if it
starts at 65 bucks it starts at 55 bucks
for you because you listen to the show
it's DST LD comm slash Ben and again get
that $10 off and you show them that you
listen to the show which means they
continue to advertise with us and that's
how we pay all the useless people who
otherwise would be unemployable behind
the scenes on this show but it's it
great pair of jeans you'll really enjoy
DLC TLD calm distilled calm slash Ben
okay so finally Barack Obama is so
desperate now that earlier this week the
White House had said that they didn't
see anything wrong with what James Comey
did in announcing that he was reopening
his investigation to Congress Obama
clearly has seen the fallout from that
hit Hillary Clinton and now he's
desperate and he too is throwing FBI
director James Comey under the bus we
don't operate on
you end no we don't operate on
incomplete information we don't operate
on leaks we operate based on concrete
decisions that are made when this was
investigated thoroughly the last time
the conclusion of the FBI the conclusion
of the Justice Department the include
conclusion of repeated congressional
investigations was that she had made
some mistakes but that there wasn't
anything there that was you know
prosecutable okay so that's that's and
it's amazing Democrats have now shifted
completely against Comey in protection
of their gal that's how you know they're
desperate well we have to break here on
Facebook and YouTube but if you want to
continue watching over to daily wire com
become a subscriber if you're an annual
subscriber and you have a free copy of
my book true allegiance signed by me
obviously if your subscriber you also
get Andrew Clavin show you get to be
part of the mailbag today we're on the
road so we can't do live mail back but
in terms of you writing in to me
while I'm on the air but I will be doing
the mailbag and your questions only get
answered in the mailbag if you are a
member at the site at daily wire.com and
and it's it is a fantastic deal when
we're adding new features all the time
we're gonna be adding new new content
that you're gonna be able to participate
in because you're a member over at Daily
wire comm check it out we are the top
conservative podcast in America
you